Metoda vzorkové kvantové diagonalizace neboli SQD je kvantově-klasický hybridní algoritmus podobně jako Krylov
kvantová diagonalizace KQD, VQE a mnoho dalších. Při používání takových hybridních
algoritmů může být užitečné přemýšlet o tom, kde každý algoritmus využívá kvantové a klasické výpočty. Vzpomeň si, že VQE vytváří stavy na kvantovém
circuit pomocí klasicky optimalizovaných parametrů. V takovém případě je samotný stav na kvantovém počítači. Přestože
dosažení cílového stavu je proces, který kombinuje klasické i kvantové výpočty.
Střední hodnota operátoru se vypočítává pomocí kvantových měření.
Ale je také nutné klasicky kombinovat některé členy.
Naproti tomu SQD využívá kvantový počítač k vygenerování užitečného podprostoru, na který lze promítnout hamiltonián nebo jiný operátor.
Hamiltonián je pak diagonalizován čistě klasicky, aby se nalezl cílový stav. Předpokládejme, že máme
problém zajímavý pro vědu nebo průmysl, který lze formulovat jako problém hledání vlastních hodnot matice o n řádcích a
n sloupcích. Předpokládejme dále, že n je dostatečně velké, takže přesná klasická diagonalizace není možná.
Bylo by zjevně výhodné zmenšit rozměry naší matice a přitom zachovat všechny relevantní vlastnosti základního stavu. A to je skutečně
cílem mnoha přibližných přístupů k hledání vlastních hodnot, včetně klasických Krylovových metod. Předpokládejme, že o svém problému víme dost na to, abychom mohli
přiměřeně dobře odhadnout tvar základního stavu, ale ne dost na to, abychom problém vyřešili přímo. V takovém
případě bychom mohli provést mnoho měření naší slušné aproximace cílového základního stavu. Výsledky těchto
měření nám dají podprostor výpočetních bázových stavů, které obsahují všechny relevantní komponenty našeho
základního stavu. Projekcí na tento podprostor bychom získali menší matici, která stále obsahuje příslušné stupně
volnosti. Postup je následující. Začni výběrem dobrého
ansatzu. Přesněji řečeno, zvol ansatz, jehož podpora se shoduje s podporou cílového stavu. Přesný význam
si vysvětlíme. Dále změř stav ve výpočetní bázi, jak se to dělá se sampler primitivem.
Pak pomocí výsledků vzorkování definuj podprostor, který obsahuje základní stav.
Potom promítni svou matici na tento podprostor. Nakonec diagonalizuj menší promítnutou matici klasicky.
Pojďme rozebrat každý z těchto kroků a věnovat zvláštní pozornost definici podprostoru.
V celém kvantovém výpočetnictví je vždy klíčové zvolit dobrý ansatz. V případě SQD tvůj výběr ansatzu
určí, které výpočetní bázové stavy mohou být naměřeny při vzorkování.
Skutečný základní stav lze vyjádřit jako superpozici nějaké podmnožiny výpočetních bázových stavů. Tato podmnožina
se nazývá podpora základního stavu. Aby ses dobře přiblížil základnímu stavu a jeho energii, musí mít tvůj ansatz
nenulovou projekci na výpočetní bázové stavy v podpoře základního stavu.
Tento diagram představuje prostor rozepnutý všemi možnými stavy na počtu qubitů, které se používají. Chceme
ansatz, jehož podpora obsahuje podporu skutečného základního stavu.
Uvažujme velmi malý příkladový systém se základním stavem s_ground = 8 *
stav 1 0 0 plus 6 * stav 0 0 1.
Tato podpora je tvořena dvěma vektory 1 0 0 a 0 0 1. Řekněme, že ansatz má tvar: ansatz 1 je A krát
stav 1 0 0 plus B * stav 0 1 0 plus C * stav 0 0 1. Takže jeho
podpora je množina tří vektorů 1 0 0, 0 1 0 a 0 0 1 – nadmnožina
podpory základního stavu. Toto je dobrý ansatz.
Nyní si představ, že bychom místo toho zvolili ansatz ve tvaru: ansatz 2 je a *
stav 1 1 0 plus b * stav 0 1 1.
Tato podpora je tvořena dvěma vektory 1 1 0 a 0 1 1, která se nepřekrývá s podporou základního
stavu. Toto je špatný ansatz.
Všimni si, že nevyžadujeme nutně, aby ansatz byl dobrou aproximací základního stavu. Ansatz může mít
mnohem větší podporu nebo koeficienty mohou být velmi odlišné u ansatzu a skutečného základního stavu a přesto může dobře fungovat.
V tomto okamžiku jsme použili dobře motivovaný ansatz, aby kvantový počítač přijal stav podobný našemu cílovému
stavu. Zde je znázorněn unitárně svázaný Jastrowův neboli UCJ ansatz, který je velmi užitečný v kvantové chemii.
Nyní chceme změřit stav systému a získat bitové řetězce popisující kolabovaný stav každého
qubitu. Vzpomeň si, že odhad hamiltoniánu jako ve VQE vyžaduje mnoho kvantových měření. Částečně proto, aby se
snížila neurčitost a částečně kvůli počtu skupin komutujících Pauliho operátorů, ze kterých se hamiltonián skládá.
Ve vzorkovacích metodách stále potřebuješ hodně měření, ale z jiných důvodů. Nyní potřebujeme mnoho měření, abychom efektivně vzorkovali
mnoho výpočetních bázových stavů zahrnutých ve vysoce provázaných kvantových stavech. V SQD odpovídají vzorkované bitové řetězce
konfiguracím simulovaného systému. Pokud je studovaný systém podřízen přísným omezením, jako jsou
zákony zachování ve fyzice nebo chemii, pak bude většina naměřených stavů platná. Ale některé vzorkované
bitové řetězce odpovídají neplatným nebo nefyzikálním konfiguracím kvůli šumu a chybám. Proces nazvaný
obnova konfigurací si klade za cíl přeměnit tyto zašuměné vzorky na sadu přesnějších konfigurací.
Tento proces zahrnuje generování nových konfigurací pravděpodobnostním překlápěním jednotlivých bitů na základě
průměrných obsazeností orbitalů a známých počtů částic.
Zpřesněné konfigurace jsou pak použity k rozepnutí podprostorů pro projekci hamiltoniánu a diagonalizaci,
čímž se iterativně zlepšuje věrnost reprezentace kvantového stavu.
Podívejme se na triviálně malý příklad obnovy konfigurací, abychom pochopili její smysl. Předpokládej, že měříme
kvantový systém se čtyřmi qubity reprezentujícími čtyři molekulární orbitaly a ze kvantového procesoru
získáme následující bitové řetězce. Každý bitový řetězec představuje obsazenost orbitalu. Jedna pro
obsazený, nula pro neobsazený. Qiskit používá notaci, ve které je nejméně významný qubit zcela vpravo.
Například 1 0 1 0 znamená, že orbitaly 1 a 3 jsou obsazeny. Tato
měření jsou zvolena pouze z pedagogických důvodů. Výsledné obsazenosti nemusí odpovídat fyzikálnímu systému. Ve fyzikálních kontextech
platí, že systém má obvykle známý celkový počet částic. Mohou existovat i další zákony zachování,
které lze využít ke zjištění fyzikality naměřeného stavu. Aby to bylo konkrétní, předpokládejme, že náš systém má
známý celkový počet částic n = 2. To nám říká celkový počet jedniček, které by se měly v našem stavovém
označení vyskytovat – tomu se říká Hammingovo váhové omezení.
Některé naměřené konfigurace však toto omezení porušují. Stav 1 0 1 0 je fyzikálně platný. Ale stav 1 1
1 0 má příliš mnoho částic a stav samých nul má příliš málo částic. Přesně
nula. Tato porušení mohou být způsobena šumem v systému nebo chybami měření. Potřebujeme způsob, jak se vrátit
ke konfiguracím, které dávají fyzikální smysl, alespoň přibližně.
Tomu se říká obnova konfigurací.
Abychom opravili naše zašuměné vzorky, pravděpodobnostně překlápíme bity v neplatných konfiguracích na základě průměrné
obsazenosti orbitalů průměrované přes platné konfigurace.
Obsazenosti orbitalů jsou střední hodnoty operátoru počtu částic působícího na každý orbital. Ty se odhadují a
iterativně zpřesňují samo-konzistentně pomocí stavů získaných z SQD. Podívejme se například na orbital 2. Ve dvou ze
čtyř platných konfigurací byl orbital 2 obsazen. To nám dává očekávanou obsazenost 0,5.
Totéž uděláme pro zbývající tři orbitaly. Nyní se vrátíme k neplatné konfiguraci 1 1 0. Můžeme překlopit jeden
z bitů z 1 na nula, abychom získali platnou konfiguraci. Ale který bychom měli překlopit? Jedním způsobem rozhodnutí je
odchylka obsazenosti každého orbitalu od průměrů, které jsme právě vypočítali.
Zde vidíme, že největší rozdíl je v obsazenosti orbitalu 1. Takže bychom mohli očekávat, že bit 1 by měl být
překlopem z jedničky na nulu. Samozřejmě orbital 2 není daleko pozadu. A vždy je možné, byť nepravděpodobné, že
tento naměřený stav je výsledkem více chyb na stejném stavu.
Výběr pouze největší odchylky od průměru pro všechny neplatné stavy není optimální. Místo toho se bity překlapují
pravděpodobnostně, přičemž pravděpodobnost je funkcí zde uvedených rozdílů. Předpokládejme, že v tomto
případě změníme bit, který se nejvíce odchyluje od průměrné obsazenosti. Takže 1 1 0 se stane 1 0 0. Stejný postup bychom provedli pro
ostatní neplatné volby. Řekněme, že v tomto případě nakonec překlopíme bity 1 a 3.
Po tomto procesu opravy máme novou sadu konfigurací, která může vypadat takto.
Pomocí této zpřesněné sady můžeme aktualizovat průměrnou obsazenost orbitalů a zlepšit věrnost. V našem případě jsou nové
obsazenosti tyto.
Tento iterativní proces obnovy zajišťuje, že zašuměná měření jsou přefiltrována na fyzikálně smysluplné
konfigurace, čímž se zlepšuje přesnost aproximací vlastních stavů v SQD. Qiskit doplněk SQD obsahuje některé nástroje,
které budou v tomto procesu nepostradatelné. Pokud jsme dobře vzorkovali stavy v podpoře skutečného základního stavu
systému, pak bychom měli být schopni podívat se pouze na části hamiltoniánu, které působí na tento podprostor,
a stále získat dobrý základní stav a energii. V našem triviálně malém příkladu se 4 qubity existuje zpočátku 2 na 4, tedy 16
možných stavů systému. Pomocí kombinace vzorkování a obnovy konfigurací toto redukujeme
na tři stavy v našem podprostoru zájmu – tři stavy, o kterých doufáme, že tvoří podporu skutečného základního stavu.
Nyní promítneme náš úplný hamiltonián na tento podprostor. To znamená, že vytvoříme matici M ze sloupce vektorů z našeho
obnoveného vzorkovaného podprostoru a analogickou M dagger z řádků, a vypočítáme M dagger H M
obrazně. To znamená vzít maticové elementy v řádcích a sloupcích odpovídajících stavům v našem
obnoveném vzorkovaném podprostoru. Zvýrazněné řádky a sloupce jsou ty, které odpovídají našemu podprostoru. A
tmavší zvýrazněné čtverce tam, kde se překrývají, jsou elementy, které si ponecháme pro naši novou promítnutou matici.
Nyní, když jsme vybrali podprostor zájmu, můžeme tuto matici diagonalizovat na klasickém počítači
pomocí standardního řešiče. Pokud je skutečný základní stav tvořen výlučně stavy v našem podprostoru, měla by tato
diagonalizace poskytnout správný základní stav a energii základního stavu. Pokud máme jen většinu podpory základního stavu,
můžeme se přiblížit. Jakmile jsme získali základní stav pro tento promítnutý hamiltonián, máme velmi
užitečný stav, ze kterého lze vypočítat průměrnou obsazenost každého orbitalu.
Dříve byly naše obsazenosti počítány ze stavů, které jsme vzorkovali pomocí ansatzu, o němž jsme doufali, že nám pomůže
přiblížit se základnímu stavu. Neexistovala však žádná záruka, že průměrná obsazenost každého orbitalu z tohoto vzorkování odpovídala obsazenosti
v energeticky nejnižším stavu. Pojďme se vrátit. Měli jsme vzorkování výpočetních stavů. Použili jsme obnovu konfigurací,
abychom opravili ty, které byly fyzikálně neplatné. Pak jsme vypočítali průměrnou obsazenost orbitalů pomocí všech z nich.
Základní stav může zahrnovat jen některé z nich. Základní stav tohoto promítnutého hamiltoniánu nemusí být skutečným základním
stavem našeho původního systému, ale je to energeticky nejnižší stav, který lze vytvořit pomocí libovolné superpozice
obnovených stavů v našem podprostoru. Obsazenost orbitalů tohoto stavu bude mít energii menší nebo rovnou
energii obsazenosti získané z obnoveného prostoru. Takže tato obsazenost je lepším odhadem naší
obsazenosti základního stavu. Proces obnovy konfigurací můžeme zopakovat s touto novou obsazeností a iterovat
tak dlouho, dokud nejsou splněna naše kritéria konvergence. Vzorkovaná kvantová diagonalizace je rychlá ve srovnání s
jinými algoritmy pro blízkou dobu jako VQE. Je více škálovatelná a je robustní vůči šumu a chybám při vzorkování.
Stále je však nutné připravit dobrý ansatz s velkou projekcí na podporu skutečného základního stavu našeho systému. Pokud není o
skutečném základním stavu vůbec nic známo, může být potřeba SQD používat ve spojení s jinými metodami, aby bylo možné
základní stav nejprve odhadnout a iterativně se k němu přiblížit.
SQD hraje klíčovou roli v rozvíjejícím se souboru klasicko-kvantových hybridních algoritmů a je jedním z
největších hybatelů směrem k užitečnému kvantovému výpočetnictví.